I saw this video it was someone holding
the baby and then they like knock on a
door nearby and they're like oh my God
I'm so sorry I hit your head and the
baby's like and it starts crying as
though it's in pain and then I saw
another video of a baby that took a
tumble like a pretty bad spill and the
mom's like oh look we just had a happy
spill this is so funny and the baby
starts laughing and like one actually
went through something and one did not
yet the responses were completely
different it really has to do with the
way that other people respond to your
trauma and then your perception of how
you should be feeling after a specified
event occur I agree people experience
trauma I just erase that things happen